is our traditional in today's world
means for a woman because tradition is
always right I think traditionals having
self-respect in yourself as a young man
but you could can you expand on that for
me and jump
in terms of self-respect like what does
that cover for you what does that when I
step out of the house I'm representing
my man okay yeah but whatever I do I'm
really step in the moment when I was a
child and I stepped out of the house
others representing my mum and dad now
when I step out the house I represent my
man so as a traditional woman anything I
do yeah
I need to remember that I'm reflecting
on him okay I appreciate that everything
I agree with you and I mean everything
from cooking cleaning anything managing
money anything I do as a traditional
woman I've always got him Forefront yeah
does that make your view correct yeah I
I agree do you think is that your right
way I didn't say it's the right way
that's what I'm expecting I'm asking
them cool the question is which is which
so Auntie when you talk about
traditional wage about cooking cleaning
don't you think the Giza should do that
as well
there you go there you go
the difference is
the woman makes a house a home no what
I'm trying to say to you is that people
get this Twisted okay right they want
they always say they want 50 50. who who
says that me women
yeah yeah yeah right yeah 50 50 might
work for some people
right but with me yeah yeah we both make
decisions but he makes the final one on
what everything everything okay but is
that your channel everything
so much you know how easy it is right to
get something and to say do you know
what
especially if it's money yeah yeah I get
it right and you say there's I'll give
you all of that and you just deal with
it yeah and I just okay I just don't
have to worry about it I get it it
doesn't take away from my Independence
it doesn't take away from me I agree in
the fact do you also appreciate and
agree the fact that if your partners was
to sit down and talk about it that you
come to a mutual agreement rather than
just letting the Giza deal with it all
I would say that we talk about he comes
with a final decision because we don't
always the final decision is always his
I don't want the finals do you
appreciate in the modern day and age
where men and women as a couple will sit
down and have that discussion together
and come to a mutual agreement but
you're making it sound like I don't sit
down and discuss don't do that
traditional people will do that you
don't just say oh the man's gonna leave
but you have just said that no matter
what you have that discussion he still
makes that final decision because if I
say your opinion my opinion doesn't
matter otherwise he wouldn't listen to
me my opinion matters and it's not all
the time that
women are always in this winning all
right then if you want to put it that
way it's not all the time that I lose
sometime I might win but at the end of
the day the final decision says okay so
when do you win then if his final
decision is his I don't want to win it's
not about winning because it's never a
competition it's never a competition
it is never a competition because there
is no decision that my man would make
that will put me at a detriment okay
so because I trust him so much with me
I will let him deal with it because I
will always come better off and as a
woman sometimes I might say no I don't
agree with that but I would just say you
know what go with it and nine times out
of ten he's always right if you don't
agree with it then his your man's still
making the decision no I will tell I
will say do you know what I'll agree to
disagree you go you go and do it and
nine times out of ten he's right okay
look the thing about it because he would
discuss it and he's got more he might
have more experience about something you
know
I've got a certificate in car
maintenance I can service the car do you
know what I mean so there's lots of
things that I can do that I don't you
know that I don't I just think honey I
think this whole thing where where
especially like with modern modern women
and even what you're prescribing to
Mason is that if if a woman allows a man
to make decisions
that it diminishes us you have to
understand men and women have different
superpowers there's a lot of power and
femininity and this is the problem like
a lot of people keep forgetting this
that women have so much power
um if they acting within their powers
power structure but you're always trying
to do things where a lot of times when I
think traditionally masculine things
where men will do for um Auntie to allow
her partner to take the lead it doesn't
administer an actual fact she's saying
right these certain things I don't need
to worry about because I try so much in
you she's not going to let the man take
her to take her to the edge of a cliff
and push her off the cliff of course
she's not stupid but at the same time
she doesn't need to be
um questioning his judgment if he leads
that any way she doesn't deem to be fit
she's gonna let him know and if he
carries on doing it he can go but at
some point you guys know it okay
well even that point she said because
there's a way to work her out but my
thing is this as long as you guys are
not willing to submit and when I say
submit this there's some nice people
need to have a nasty connotation with
the word submit submit doesn't mean
um getting on one knee and and
worshiping your man it means trusting
his leaders which means he's not going
to lead me down the wrong path and as
long as you guys keep fighting because
you said you've been in your mouth for
four years and you're younger so that's
really good like I want to see you guys
progress I don't want you to be one of
these girls out in the first he's mad
because no because that's what happens
what happens is if you prescribe to a
lot of the things that people say you
might get a good guy
and you might end up losing this good
guy and then you're gonna go along the
pathway and then you get Alpha widowed
you never find another guy that's good
at this guy I didn't just end up being
out in your 30s and you get mad you end
up like a lot of these girls in the
house waves so I'm saying to you and
this is what happens no no no but I'm
giving you something I'm giving you
something it's not you because you're 23
and you've got a manual now but in 10
years time that could easily be you 33
and these are the women that I interact
with and by the time they get to this
age they are mad they're frustrated
they've got high body counts and they've
got unagreeable attitudes and they're
not willing to change and that's all
they bring us men and then they meet men
like yo and he runs through them quickly
do you know why no no simply it means
right right quickly
no but what I mean is end of the day is
is is like we're trying to give you some
information because obviously you're a
bit younger and you've got a man that
the man that loves you by the end of the
day if you want to play the game you can
play this game and and that that little
thing where you had the U for youth upon
you which makes you better than a lot of
these other girls you're going to lose
that everyone gets older you know what
I'm trying to say to you and then you
don't become that 23 year old in the
club no more or know them in actual fact
you become that older woman that let a
lot of opportunities that good I'm not
I'm not that woman not no but you're not
but they're not making a good point I
know you are not her there's a lot of
women that are yeah I am not sure so I
am not sure you know what I find that's
really hard gone a lot of women talk but
they don't listen well they don't listen
because he's trying to give you the best
advice I know you're not you're not even
letting him
finishing I mean I'm finishing I'm
talking now and he's going to give you
just I was going to give you some advice
and he was just talking so much sense
because because I feel like you're
agreeing with him um no because I'm not
Captain do you know what I'm doing do
you know why I'm hungry as well
constantly not because he's a man
because I agree with you when you said
that you turned down right I agreed with
you when you were saying about the
fantastic the woman I hope you're going
to get invite me to the wedding I agreed
with you when you were saying that
you're honest and open and I agree with
him so I'm not just picking I don't just
agree just my thing is this my thing is
this rather than trying to battle
against what a man is saying like do you
keep you want to act like I'm an anomaly
I'm not an anomaly I represent a lot of
men and the problem in the past is men
haven't spoken and a lot of these guys
like him sorry keep using you but I want
to use you have an example because he's
a good looking guy that's out there
getting good results they're not going
to tell you this they don't give a damn
about your body count because they're
not going to hang around long enough for
it to matter they're gonna run it up and
give it to your husband but when you
meet a guy like me that actually wants
to marry you and then yo and Mason have
run for your body how has that helped me
what have you done for me so so so me as
a guy I'm saying a lot of these things
because women don't want to listen and
the average man he's not going to say
anything to you because he doesn't want
to risk it being called misogynistic or
you can't tell women what to do with
their bodies as soon as men talk like
this we get shot down I do agree because
you're the only winner guys serious yeah
and I'll be honest with you you like
this is coming from when a man is
serious about you he doesn't waste no
time men know what they want so men
understand that another man can pull up
the ball in a Lambo see your wife and
say oh oh what's your name she's like I
got a man he's like where's your ring
you ain't got a ring and then that's it
because it's not yours it's just your
turn thank you oh wow
can I just ask you a quick question
what's your views on Andrew Tate
do you respect Andrew Tai or are you
against what he believes in like not
like I'll be honest with you
um like I never followed him but I only
I only saw the clips on him based on
Business and Entrepreneurship and
talking about getting out the Matrix and
those types of stuff those are the
things but all the other stuff that I
saw I saw like obviously a lot of stuff
have been taken out of context but I
also agree that no one should be banned
because even Trump shouldn't be banned
because when you start when you silence
someone all that you say they've got
something to say yeah and there's a lot
more people that are dangerous have more
dangerous views I've not been silenced
the real reason is
the misogyny but it's really more about
him telling men that we need to go to
the gym we need to become entrepreneurs
yeah just stuck after your women yeah we
need to look after women stop stop
letting people like [ __ ] on you this is
what's going to happen in the future to
Communists go out and become make your
money become more become more productive
and then go out there and finally get a
woman yeah and the most important things
that I remember that you said it was
about letting his woman go out to clubs
of his woman with his girlfriend with
her girlfriends yeah
anyone who doesn't believe Andrew speaks
common cities because they're not
probably listened to him they've only
listened to sound bites of what he said
taken out a contest to God he's a
misogynist facts facts facts and and
that's what I feel like like not even
that was that's what I feel like that's
what I know because from what I've
listened to Andrew Tate I already know
what is like if you cannot pick if
you're going to take away the little you
know some of the things he says the
world
don't listen to how he says it listens
to what he says yeah and so when he's
saying those waffles I'll be like bro
that probably didn't help you what you
said yeah say something else I'll be
like yes and that's what I followed him
for it was all about
um becoming better as a man
um it was all about you know
entrepreneurship building a business all
about treating a woman better in actual
fact
um if you're not ready to be that man
you better just leave that woman like
what you were saying go out there become
productive do these things and then once
you do then come back and do that and
that's what I pretty much got from
agitate yeah that's exactly but you
basically just described exactly his
philosophy and what he believes in yeah
I heard a lot about what you said that's
why I was asked that's why I asked you a
few yeah just because I'll be honest
with you like like I've got I've got
three sisters and my mom and my dad I've
grown up in a family unit like I said
I'm not married that's what marriage for
me that's that's a goal family for me is
is is one of the most important things
and and being out here I can accept some
thoughts I've had in the early years but
like I said
um I fully understand what type a woman
that I want I fully understand what type
of man that I am I I like I said I don't
mind coming and grinding and giving the
money to the woman and saying to the
woman you run the household like let me
you know what I'm trying to say to you
these are these aren't things yeah these
songs stress up your head man I don't
want to worry about this stuff like I
don't want to worry about something no
but I trust him I don't want to worry
about it no I don't understand when
people say it comes down to trust but
why are you going to sleep with somebody
you don't trust no but this is your boys
back to their entire conversation about
I don't care where you go you're walking
into Australian right with man there but
I trust you I don't trust the man we
spoke about this bro but I still
wouldn't go in a hostile environment
that's a hostile environment I honestly
believe hostile environment sorry my man
potential if my if I said to my man I'm
going to a club yeah and I didn't know
about that club and he knew about the
club and he said you know what I don't
think you should go there because blah
blah blah blah blah even though the
choice is mine even no even though the
choice is mine yeah like you said you
might have seen a couple of fights like
he might have seen a couple of fights
might have heard something that I
haven't heard of yeah
I'm going to give him the benefit the
doubt but because I mean I'd rather be
safe than sorry and it's not that he's
stopping me from going it's just that
I'm gonna make an informed decision I'll
get that of course and um
I'm gonna Round Up Now final thoughts
I want to know what you thought about
this show and whether you see yourself
as traditional and modern or whether you
want traditional or modern upper halves
yeah um
so yeah my final thoughts on today was
just that like when you as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible